[Music]
hi everyone it is time for the truth
News podcast where we're serving you up
all the news that you need a little bit
of Pop Culture things that aren't on the
top lines of things a little bit of
inspo a whole lot of feel Goods the
functions and the findings today we're
covering everything from a fashion
fumble involving Chelsea Clinton and
Oprah to the secrets of a long life from
the oldest woman in the world oh my
goodness I want to hear that I want a
panic spiral and get inspired all at the
same time I am here with comedian actor
Sam Jay
and your new movie you people which by
the way has the most amazing cast comes
out on Netflix today how did it feel
working with Jonah Hill Eddie Murphy
every time the cab goes by with the
poster I'm like no that's a cast
overwhelming this is my first movie so
yeah I've never done a movie before have
you been around a while I've been around
a little bit Yeah so this was my first
like feature so it was like you you know
you step on the movie sets and it's just
bigger everything's bigger and you're
like whoa a lot of money was spent and
then you're like you feel the pressure
to step it up and perform so it was
overwhelming but in the best kind of way
like challenging in all the right ways I
like that you said it makes you feel
like you have to step it up and perform
because I'm struggling so badly I can't
even lie about it I am just I am
struggling right now I feel like a total
fraud I'm so sorry I'm like spiraling
I'm just I feel off physically today I
feel off emotionally and even if I put
that out there then I can proceed
because at least I'm honest about it I
even like said something some person was
like did you see that I was like ah I
didn't see it I never say it like that I
don't know who I am today I'm like Linda
Blair and The Exorcist but like inward I
I just am having a hard day how's your
day it's all right I had a rough day
yesterday so I feel you I was really I
was going through it yesterday did you
get over it oh man I had to be honest
about it and I had to be like yeah this
is wild but I'm gonna to try to push
through like a friend of mines went
missing and like it was like it was a
lot oh my God it was a spectacle level
that sounds like real problem and then I
had to like try to shake it off and like
go do some stuff and I totally get it
and um I'm okay so like thank you did
they find your friend though yeah we've
we found him okay okay that's good yeah
so I'm I get it I give being a little
off don't worry about it oh my God I'm
having one of the most surreal days of
my life in a long time I don't know what
it is I feel like I'm on the outside
looking in or the inside looking out I
just it's it's a little bit of a surreal
bizarre feeling I don't know what's
wrong with me it happens I think I've
definitely had that experience where
it's like you kind of just feel like
you're moving like something's pushing
you but it's not you and you're just
kind of like
yes and you want you feel untethered
it's like oh I need to yes I feel
untapped other little like weird and
druggy and surreal even though I'm not
on drugs at all yeah
um thank you for and I'm is your day
better since yesterday yes yes yes I
feel a lot better well I'm going to call
you tomorrow and tell you how great my
day is and how much better it is than
today because it's gonna start getting
better right now I look forward to that
thank you now I feel so happy to proceed
because I'm not anybody
I will say that always when I read the
news it always makes me feel better
because there's always something weird
and cool and interesting and it's like
the segment that pulls me up and out the
most so thank you for doing this and I'm
so happy that we're tackling this
subject and not something else because
the news really does Lift Me Up it can
it can this is the different news this
is that b side of news news you can use
the news that we need more of I think I
do a PBS on like Nightly News
a a CNN whoa
yes I'm I'm a newsie and it's why I want
this news all the more because we have
to have the antidote because there are
good things happening and weird cool
findings and so there's this magazine
called the week and it just has a tiny
paragraph called it wasn't all bad and
this segment that's cool it's completely
inspired by that thank you so much of
course now it's going to be amazing I
can be real I hate being a faker and it
doesn't work either you know what I mean
like you end up just feeling off and
weird and fraudulent and you're like
this isn't servicing anybody no I want
to be myself and a human and be all 100
all right thank you of course yeah Sam
um all right should we hit some
headlines let's do it perfect first up
happy 100 wait no oh my God I did read
that right oh my gosh happy
115th birthday to Maria Maria she just
became the world's oldest living person
Maria sets her secrets to a long life
are order Tranquility good connections
with family and friends and nature
emotional stability having no regrets
lots of positivity and staying away from
toxic people
holy cow
Sammy just celebrated a birthday
thoughts from this amazing beautiful
woman's wisdom I mean
115 is a that's a long life man I
thought I was reading it wrong that's a
long life it's like that's a weird thing
too because it's like I don't know that
I would want to live that long
115 I would you would I would yeah 115.
yeah because my kids and oh okay and
then that makes sense and my daughter
said this morning because they had some
brownies last night and they wanted one
for breakfast and I was like I'll be
cool there were tiny squares I was like
sure and then I made them eggs and then
a little Nutella test and I said God you
know I shouldn't have allowed you to
have a little a piece of brownie because
you're having a piece of Nutella toast
that's like too much of a good thing and
Frankie grabbed her little brownie
square and she goes will I live longer
if I don't eat it and I go yes and she
handed it back to me really yeah and
then I turned around and bit my fist
like the woman in Airplane thinking how
many things I've done to cut my life
shorter
I get like kids yeah I have a cat I
think I want to live as long as my cat
like well that is not that's not a long
enough that's my kid my cat is my kid I
know but they only live like 20 years
Max
I'm cool with that no Sam that's not
enough time you have to live longer we
need you longer selfishly yeah all right
all right I'll stay no I mean I think
it's like one of the things I do think
is real it was like that elimination of
like toxic people and like yo energy I
think that's so important as it's it's
high up on the list of any type of
longevity kind of in anything you do
it's just like protecting yourself and
protecting your energy did you always
know that or did you have to learn it I
had to learn that for sure that's like a
more I think late 20s early 30s
Revelation I agree with that time
assessment and I grew up so fast and
worked since I was a baby and I always
think my timelines are a bit off but
that is I think in
not sort of how you grow up or where the
way you grow up it's like that time
invested in the world and being on this
planet seems to be similar for a lot of
people 20s 30s you kind of go
you know what yeah this is where you
start to turn some Corners yeah I think
you really start to think about what
kind of life you want I think through
your 20s you're just like
doing stuff oh my God I was such an
idiot yeah you have no real clear idea
like what kind of person you want to be
I just wanted to have fun yeah I wanted
to work hard and play hard I want to
burn that candle at both ends and have
the best time doing it did you yes
that's awesome that's important too but
then I got into my 30s and everything
late 20s early 30s everything changed I
started working with the UN I started
thinking about having kids I was single
for a while
um I kind of cooled out
um rethought my job and my life and then
by I would say around 34 like everything
had changed same yeah same and I feel
like I was ready to get my life together
and then it fell apart horrendously but
I picked it back up but you're ready to
pick it back up I think you learned from
those old lessons and it is going to
fall apart again you know like it'll
keep building and crumbling and building
and grumbling but the older you get the
more you're like I know how to clean
this up it's just not the end of the
world you recognize it faster and you
have a better set of tools and life is a
roller coaster and it has highs and lows
and the dips
you know are surprising that they can be
so big at times because you're like wait
I'm older I should have learned I didn't
see this coming I didn't think this
would take me down so far yes that's
what's crazy to me is like you get to
these places and you think like yo I
beat this thing yes I've got this and
then it like shows its face in this like
other way and you're like whoa like I am
like completely rocked right now in a
way that I didn't think was like
possible anymore you know like my
grandma passed away recently I'm so
sorry and I was like really destroyed by
it in a way that I didn't expect because
my mom passed away when I was young and
when I went through that and it took me
years to kind of find my way out of what
that was losing your mother at 16 you
know but when I did I was like okay I
get this I understand myself my
relationship with death like if death
presents itself to me again I'm gonna be
like okay and then I was like I am so
not okay and I didn't expect to feel it
but then I just had to let myself feel
it you know what I mean I was like stop
trying to like manage this and just let
yourself have these feelings and you'll
you will get to the side which I learned
from my mother it was like you have the
tools though to bring yourself to the
other side of whatever this feeling is
and I think that's the real takeaway
that we take from all these experiences
are those tools like you said I
um I'm so sorry about your grandmother
and was she like a mother figure to you
yeah it was like going through that all
over it in a way I didn't expect and
also weirdly I felt like the last
connection I had to my mom was gone it
was like this is the person who can tell
me like stories this is the person who
really knew her this is the person I can
tap as a resource of that and it was
like oh now this resource is gone and it
kind of felt like being orphaned again a
little bit it was like whoa this kind of
feels crazy it was weird and my brothers
all felt the same way like we finally
had to talk about it and they were like
yo I didn't think it was gonna mess with
me as much as it did either and I was
like yeah I just thought I don't know I
don't know I don't know why I would
think that but I did
the arrogance of people you know what I
mean thank you
I'm so honored to have that conversation
with you and it's like I know we talk
about news and fun stuff and you know
who knows the next Story coming could be
like about a pigeon pooping you know on
some woman's head and she's suing the
landlord like I don't even know what's
next but I that's a big part of why I
love comedy is because when it all gets
big and heavy like the sigh of relief to
lighten up and laugh or really shift my
energy
um laughter and tears or like twins they
kind of look alike and sound alike and
functional like and I like The Duality
and the sort of pendulum that swings so
wide and far with both
um but thank you for talking to me about
that because I I really appreciate that
you can think that you have dealt with
things and then it can come back at
another point in a different form at
another time in life and you will have
to reprocess all over again and yet what
I'm going to take away also from what
you shared is that in the end you told
yourself I've gotten through things
before and I will get through things
again and it comes back around as you
said yes and that is something to never
lose sight of like the true love life
raft you know and you hang in there
Kitty and it's like you got through this
you will get through it again that is
not only hopeful but it's very pragmatic
because you have your own truth to fall
back on which ironically my therapist
talks about part X and when it works
negatively it usually works for me too
so you don't know how to decipher it but
that's the positive version yeah I'm
into that all right well here we go with
the next story Sam if you're ready let's
see where this one takes us next in
fashion fumble news Chelsea Clinton
recently shared that in her dash out the
door she accidentally put on two very
different pair of black heels one with a
pointed toe and one with a peep toe
Chelsea hope no one would notice but of
course the one and only Oprah Winfrey
did Oprah laughed and said she thought
it was a new fashion trend before
Chelsea explained that it was
unintentional Sam thoughts I've done
something like that it's not it's not
impossible it's not important it's not
it happens to the best of it happens to
the best of us like I've definitely done
some some silly stuff like getting
dressed with my clothes thinking I think
the biggest one you think you have on
like black and black and then you get
out and realize it's like navy blue and
you're like oh
I'm ruined I think that's like one that
everyone kind of has done at some point
but I've done I've done some stuff done
some stuff put on my underwear backwards
oh and not realize it until I like go to
use the bathroom in public and I'm like
my underwear on backwards do you wear a
big girl underwear like I wear big girl
underwear like as in like there's the
underwear themselves they're a big girl
they're they're big they're they're
they're Hefty they're they're they're
girthy they're like you could use it as
a parachute in an emergency all the time
yes pretty much and I then I'll try to
wear like a hipster or like a skim which
occasionally I will wear and today I've
been picking out my underwear all day
from places I did not expect for them to
be in and I'm like this is where why I
wear my big girl underwear and when I
say big girl I'm picturing like
full-blown granny panty like the sides
are at least six inches long now you can
put a baby in it and the baby could
swing it's a total baby be diaper like
safety pin the side stitch cool I'm not
mad at that okay I'm not I'm not mad at
it I'm a boy shorts person myself oh
that's like a good boy short and because
they don't crawl up into you know
nefarious crevices that you don't want
anything in yeah yeah I can't go back to
those type of like trying to be cute
panties like when I was trying to be
cute those are those are panties I can't
go back to panties I need drawers Sam
I'm never gonna say it differently
I'm done with panties it's all about
drawers yeah you need drawers draws
um all right we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break and we'll be right back
[Music]
and we are back I'm here with Sam Jay
okay up next a music lover named Fatima
recently went viral on Tick Tock for
getting a QR code tattoo of her favorite
Spotify playlist why you ask so she
could show the code to any DJ and they
could scan it and she could dance all
night long to all her favorite songs
okay do you love this idea I mean I
don't hate it
because I am the girl who brings there
used to be like mixtape then it became
the iPod now it's all in the iPhone
um and I have a lot of playlists and I
do put a lot of playlists on Spotify and
I'm a big playlist like junkie so I kind
of really get where she's going and if
she could put like 150 songs on there
everywhere you go boom insta party uh I
feel like DJ's hate request though oh
they don't make requests you know what I
mean like everything that I know they
get annoyed requests but then and now
you're requesting a whole playlist that
seems a little obnoxious you know what
you're totally right
yes you're absolutely right What DJ is
gonna roll over and just like your
playlist yes no this is impossible I
didn't think it was a good plan no this
plan is full of holes
and by the way I would say then just
play it at a friend's house or at your
home but you don't need a QR code for
that no you need a plug exactly oh my
God Sam you really broke this down in a
way that made me think from good idea to
absolutely not good idea and I I also
remember my last encounter with the DJ I
it was my daughter's 10th birthday and
I've never had a DJ they they worked at
the venue I I was like oh it's double
digits we've only ever thrown a party in
our apartment or at our Auntie Jill's
House like that's it this was like a big
girl party this was you know a first
double digit it was you know a lovely
little moment
um but the place had a DJ and I was like
oh that's so cool okay but but um the
first 10 minutes of the party I started
spiraling because it was really hardcore
like real I don't how do I even put this
the music felt dirty like it was it was
like hardcore like it did not feel 10
year old's birthday it wasn't like Kidz
Bop oh no no no no no no no no no no no
it was like inappropriate DJ went off
yeah and I was like I am so sorry to ask
this but I'm starting to feel really
uncomfortable with parents like I've
invited them into like an inappropriate
party would it be okay to like play like
I don't know like Harry Styles and I
could tell this guy wanted to kill me
like he was I need to know what he
really pissed off and it was you're
right DJs don't want to be told what to
do it was like very grinding like oh
okay I feel like there might have been
some appropriate words like Pretty Ricky
type stuff it was like I felt very
vulnerable in front of all the parents
like welcome to this very inappropriate
birthday party second the music changed
the feeling went away yeah I mean you
were correct you shouldn't you shouldn't
be playing grinding like Pretty Ricky
Style songs at a 10 year old's party it
was like I'm so sorry sir but could we
just take it down a notch and I don't
know Harry Styles Taylor Swift like
which is still like the coolest like
cool we would have like literally killed
me if I said Kidz Bop I wouldn't even
dare you know like I'm over Kidz Bop I
get it like but everything changed the
second this like very hardcore like the
only thing you wanted to do is wrap your
legs around something and start like
grind that's what the soundtrack of life
was
so yeah you're right DJs don't want to
be told their business because that's
their business is DJ that's what they do
it's like their art yes exactly all
right well this you're right about this
story and it is wrong okay moving on
Trevor Noah the greatest man ever
recently left The Daily Show and
compared the grind of making a Daily
Show to planning a wedding but without
the honeymoon comedians like Leslie
Jones Wanda Sykes Sarah Silverman and
Chelsea Handler are all slated to guest
hosts Sam you wrote on Saturday Night
Live for Four Seasons what do you think
about the roster of uh first of all I
just want to say women that they're
bringing in yeah because there's no
women in late night yeah no I think it's
cool I think except for Amber refin I
like that they're mixing it up one I
think that's fun that they're just like
letting us see different hosts every
week it's such a different approach to a
thing where they're usually just like
anchor it with one person so it's just
been fun watching different people's
takes on things and what they have to
say and it's just always though when you
see more diversity and a space to me you
know what I mean like of all kinds it's
like the more you see that then the
better off we are if it feels like a
push in the right direction I I'm very
excited for it I'm really glad to hear
you say that I I trust you and through
talking to you like I feel like I just
want to do what Sam says you know I do I
like I I really like have come to
implicitly trust your gut instincts on
things there's some good diversity
happening in late night man because
there's Amber show there's z-way show I
love by the way I love Z-Wave and I've
done her show and I panicked afterwards
because I was like oh God what did I
just say because you wanted to show up
and I love zue and then z-we came here
um she's been here a few times
um love her yeah she's great at it she's
great at it there's my show there's
pause yep so this will feel there's some
stuff going on in late night yeah yeah
it's an exciting little space right now
you're absolutely right and I'm really
glad to see women come up because
honestly a year or two or three ago
there were almost no women in late
nights yeah and that just didn't feel
right to me it didn't feel like reading
the room and it didn't feel like there
was an offering to choose and also now
there's so much diversity in the style
like I think about like Amber show and
I'm like that's one way and now you have
zeeway who's approaching Yale another
way that you have my show which
approaches it a whole another way and so
you're also getting like all these
different looks of late night when I
feel like before it was always just like
here's a desk here's one person and
they're gonna talk at you now I think
we're starting to have more whole
conversations and finding a lot of ways
into these different conversations who
was an inspiration for you starting your
show
oh man Chris Rock show on HBO
um Arsenio I I got to do an Arsenio I
think I was on I don't know at least
once or twice but I loved it and I I
thought it was like just the coolest
place to be and I was so that's what I
loved about it yeah it felt like um
a younger cooler party yeah it was like
there was nothing like it yeah I mean
and it was a conversations were like
relaxed in a way that I hadn't seen late
night be it was like we're really
kicking it he was a very good
interviewer too as far as he had a very
honest disarming quality he kept it
really real
um you knew he could bust into funny at
any moment so there was always that
levity in the air which is what I think
comedians do and create a safe space but
he also explored depth and you know had
hard conversations and I was just such
an Uber fan of his I was so thrilled
that he would have me on a show and we
talked about some deep stuff together
and then as a viewer I loved watching
you know one of the things that I also
enjoy is not knowing exactly what I'm
gonna get and I feel like Oprah's show
was always like that is today going to
be in-depth meaningful poignant and
life-changing or is it going to be
entertainment or is it going to be
something like home spun and domestic
and like life improving we need to be
kept on our toes because life does that
or have many different interests many
different subjects many different things
we're tackling I want heavy I want light
I want everything in between so the
diversity of hosts the diversity of
subjects and tones yes is so important
yeah and I think we're seeing that in a
really cool way well I cannot wait to
like watch what the Daily Show evolves
into in this chapter it always has taken
me a minute like John Oliver and Trevor
Noah like you know from Jon Stewart all
transitions but
is there anyone I love more than Jon
Stewart John Oliver and Trevor I don't
know no like those three dudes are so
legendary so it reminds me also to like
give it a minute and settle in because
you may just be watching like your new
favorite person for sure for sure all
right Sam you brought us the last story
tell us everything yes I wanted to talk
about uh Shannon sharp today actually so
Shannon sharp had a altercation at a
Lakers game a Lakers Grizzlies game and
he got into it with some of the players
on the floor while he was a spectator
there was some yelling back and forth
the referees had to come out it was a
big thing he was arguing with the
players they had to break it up and he
was a a guest a guest at the games
member yes and then today he apologized
on his show he apologized for his
behavior he apologized to the fans he
apologized to the Grizzlies he
apologized to the Lakers he apologized
to LeBron personally because he was like
you know you've been my friend and
you've always stood up for me and I'm
sorry you had to stand up for me in a
moment like this and I just thought it
was so cool I thought it was just so
cool that he a person in the spotlight
who could easily act like he wasn't the
problem or keep arguing his stance or
use his show as a platform to defend
himself he just took a moment to say
like publicly yo I messed up and I think
it was dope because people mess up
that's what actually happens in real
life and we need spaces and the ability
to say sorry and for him to just stand
and do that in such a big way I was like
wow what an example of like how to do it
correctly because you're not never going
to do something wrong
these hugs are good by the way I really
need them and I feel so compelled I
can't hold back for anything I just want
to get in there and hug you because you
make such important points
um I don't know why
we don't either make it more safe and
welcoming for people to apologize
or to have some self-introspection I
hate that also
an understanding of a self-awareness or
a revelation also has to come with an
apology that means shame I've done
something really wrong like I know
because I have had moments where I've
you know you really have to come out and
apologize for your behavior you know and
I think it can distract also from the
real thing which is nobody is perfect we
hold exactly people in politics or power
or in the spotlight or any human being
now on social media to a standard that
is almost impossible to live up to and
when they don't it's aha
and if anybody has to learn a lesson or
do it in front of people which I've been
in those shoes where you learn hard
stuff right in front of everybody now
everybody is having that life experience
I kind of never expected that we would
all be in this together and my empathy
and respect is just it's so there
because that is also
all actions aside in a moment modeling
for every person on the planet
to be able to change their mind have
some recognition change their stance
share the other side of it okay this is
the aftermath
I love that story so much and I hope it
can open doors for people to feel
compelled to say hey this is how I'm
feeling about this experience now
because we've not made it comfortable
for people and therefore they are
doubling down on the wrong yeah and
they're also afraid nothing works when
it becomes like fear-mongering they're
afraid of what they're gonna lose
they're afraid they're going to lose
their their job their livelihood or
whatever and we threatened that they
will lose everything you will be
canceled so it's like well now I'm just
not gonna even said anything wrong no I
didn't it's like it makes you kind of
force that stronghold in a way that I
don't think helps anybody you know
nobody's growing in that type of
situation nobody's growing we have to
start like really championing people
saying I've had a mayor culpa I've had a
revelation I've I remember in in
politics if someone changed their minds
they were accused of being a
flip-flopper and that was a bad thing
it's like are you serious we are not
born with a set of values and that value
system stays exactly the same until the
day we die at hopefully 115 years old
right now exactly you are going to
change and grow and have incredible
introspection and we should want that
and encourage that yeah because that's
what makes people whole well screw all
the other stories Sam yours is better
and I totally agree no Spotify playlist
on your arm
unless it makes you happy and in which
case then absolutely go for it more
diversity and women and incredible you
know options and opportunity in late
night and being absolutely cheering on
and giving space to people who want to
grow and learn and change right in front
of everybody because it's kind of what
we're all doing yeah
yeah
and then we did it we did it we fixed
America there was that woman may we all
live a long life and not do everything
we can to sabotage it along the way or
live a little bit longer than your cat
you know what you need nine lives
samj needs nine lives that probably will
measure out to about 115.
um Sam thank you so much for doing this
today can we do more together yeah it
was fun it's really nice to like get to
know you keep it real love laugh think
uh hug Good Hugs talk about deep stuff
and like cats cats important yeah cats
are important yeah I'm really into my
cat what shout out to fancy fancy yeah
how old is fancy four okay a lot of got
a lot of years left
um and um fluffy domestic what type of
Persian oh White
[Applause]
[Music]
yes oh you went that route interesting I
would like to see a picture one day
maybe you can bring Fancy by the studio
he's he lives up to his name he he lamps
on things he lounges very well I have
four cats do you yep I do see you know
what's up I have the cat lady yeah you
know what's up um Sam thank you so much
thank you and maybe can I ask you you
know sometimes we say tell a friend or
let somebody know about a podcast share
the word what's a good way to share the
word I think person to person just
talking to folks being I think we need
to go back to talking to each other more
and just really being interpersonal well
the next time you have a conversation
with someone tell them about the podcast
because I will say in all sincerity and
no silliness I would want to hear this
podcast today because I want to listen
to what you have to say so that was
sweet thank you share this with someone
so you can listen to Sam and want to hug
her the way I so luckily know of her
like that was a good four times
um all right well follow us wherever you
get your podcast and if you like you
know like I said tell a person IRL or
who you're talking to all about Sam J
and um be as happy as I am listening to
her and sharing in her space and watch
the Drew Barrymore show every weekday by
going to the Drew grammarshow.com and
find your local time and channel and as
always we make this show for you so take
it with you
yay oh nice thank you so much